au pq
sous la pluie
pascal deschamps vous intervenez quand
vous voulez
l'étude de paul frictionne s'est alors
complètement la outsiders du festival
cantine tarantino à 30 ans il avait fait
l'événement il ya deux ans hors
compétition et café s'appelait reservoir
dogs qui avait été projeté à minuit et
qui avait été saluée par tout le monde
est là donc il était en compétition
samedi soir est donc déjouant tous les
pronostics
c'est lui qui obtient 7 cette palme d'or
pour pulp fiction
c'est un film parodique sur les
histoires policières publié dans l'est
dans les années 50 dans des magazines
bon marché et donc cancun tarantino est
un grand lecteur
mado le sort réservé à l'image de
quentin tarantino il n'arrive pas à
prononcer ces remerciements parce qu'il
est il est absolument fou de joie il
rigole il ya tous ses amis dans la salle
ils acclament processus est une surprise
pour lui aussi
bien aimé revenir expect voilà dix-sept
réponse que j'appelle est absolument
dans sa lutte ou de récompense de ses
jeunes fans des canaris pour elle mais
drôle connaissent donc tous les membres
des jurys mourant parce que oui nous
allons devoir interrompre cette ruine
les wampas sont donc les six américains
là ont bien fait de ne pas bouder le
festival non puisqu'ils repartent avec
une palme d'or il faut peut-être
préciser puisque nous en sommes là le
grand prix spécial du jury en dessous le
comté très attendu voilà deux grand prix
du jury ex-aequo vivre du chinois et le
sai trompeur de nikita mikhalkov
merci beaucoup parce que nous sommes en
fin de journal avec vos invités à tout
de suite il y a